BAM what's happening you bad
[ __ ] yong-chol Joey here we're
breaking it interrupting when you're
watching to take a [ __ ] smoke break
you man you're not doing too good your
fantasy team is falling apart you
[ __ ] mutt your team ain't cover the
spread
never fail cool Joey to cheer you up
with the refre debt I got the Russian
[ __ ] is the Last Temptation of Christ
and I got some [ __ ] hardcore you know
just to join it I what did you get to us
I choked that I made no progress today
but my fat ass sweat and that's all that
[ __ ] matters at the end of the day
understanding enough is enough Joey
you're gonna [ __ ] smoke : I got
caught up by a spiderweb in the Garden
of Good and Evil nothing like smoking a
ball on the Lord's Day with your
favorite [ __ ] people in the world
understand me you know meat though ain't
got time to play games of for
chitter-chatter
I'm just looking to get stoned I can lie
the entire bunch of shitless and Who am
I here with you see anybody here jumping
up and down I'm trying to be sad I don't
want to be nobody I just want to be a
fat storm and be left to [ __ ] alone you
understand me
I got goals I got admirations well not
admirations aspirations that's the
[ __ ] word right there let's face it
I'm no rocket science
but I know that going in and that's the
most important [ __ ] thing in the
world you want to smoke the ball you
uncle Joey's here enough uncle Joey
spark another bull this weed is so
[ __ ] good this Last Temptation of
Christ I smoked that [ __ ] I spoke to you
this morning I tried to go to jujitsu I
didn't know where I was going the arm
bars are backwards
that's the [ __ ] weed I heard Japanese
people yelling I told you once I told
you 2,000 times if you smoke dope and
you hear Japanese people yelling you're
onto the dope go back to the ATM unload
that [ __ ] buy this [ __ ]
but anyway
smoke signals for the [ __ ] Indians
they gotta get invited to the party too
I mean regardless they were here first
I suppose up in this hard quote they
show these [ __ ] little hard
core from perennial this will put you
where you need to be read like I say I'm
not gonna show up on one good weed on
one bad weed I'm gonna show up a
blueberry flavor that I don't do that
[ __ ] I show you know what I want I want
the flavor a debt I want to sit down and
drool from my [ __ ] mouth like a
[ __ ] that's reefer
that's when I get my hands on that's not
what you want go smoke a little sativas
with your friends huh
I love that it tastes the filter hell
[ __ ] yourself I'm crawling Headey I'm
sacrificing for you [ __ ] [ __ ]
and you're over here what's smoking out
of a filter to be cool like you [ __ ]
partners get tough daddy
it's either a pipe a [ __ ] big bamboo
from POJO it
tremendous I'm ready for [ __ ]
anything my wife the baby there is
[ __ ] Church they went to Gelson's to
get some [ __ ] chicken cutlets I'm
gonna sit right here I got a right a
little bit I gotta get my week sorted
out I gotta prepare for the podcast at
like 8:00 p.m. be there or be [ __ ]
square you understand me Oh Corrections
[ __ ] the wool Bettina solved
out
thanks to you [ __ ] so it looks
like he's driving to Connecticut things
are the Foxwoods will have a good time
they get a [ __ ] fight Oh beyond we're
going to the bar do a little fight
companion who's better than you the
eyeball is death tell me was [ __ ]
battling you know buddy well I don't
take a genius attire I'm stoned to the
[ __ ] gills already I'm sorry I said
to do and people to see
I won't bump into you [ __ ] up isn't a
few hours before the church all right
you know I love you have a great day
with your family that's the most
important than the Lord's Day everything
else is background music you wanna hang
with your buddies at the bar like a
bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ] to eat stay on
with your family hangout and that's it I
love you [ __ ]